hello everyone and welcome to round
eight of defeat hs.com grand swiss a lot
of you guys have already requested this
and of course for good reasons it's
alireza firuja versus krishnan
and it's a game that could very well uh
decide the the first place of this event
and who will classif uh qualify uh for
the uh next uh cycle of the feed a
candidate's tournament uh it's a very
very enjoyable uh you know a lot to
cover so let's dive straight into it so
both of them without a single loss so
far now let's see what happens so
alireza with the white pieces opens with
e4
we have e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to c4 going for the italian game
we have bishop to c5 the joko piano and
now uh you could go for quite a few
moves here b4 is often a popular move
you know amongst the many attacking
players uh but this is a very important
game so uh alersa goes for the more
solid main line of the joko piano he
plays c3
we have knight to f6 and now d3 you
could also advance the pawn all the way
to d4 but this this just keeps the
tension and you know
keeps more stuff on the board uh so here
we have castles by black castle by white
and now that d5 black says all right
you're not going to open up the center i
will so he captures on the five knight
captures and rook to e1 putting pressure
on the e5 pawn and this is nothing new
all this has been played before bishop
to g4 just spinning the knight here
knight b to d2 now you have to deal with
this annoying pin for
some time but like i said this is
explored territory so nothing to worry
about uh knight b6 attacking the bishop
bishop back to b3 but not right away
first we're gonna attack black's bishop
with h3 and now the thing is uh you
can't really
use this opportunity to eliminate one of
white's uh bishops for example if knight
captures knight captures your bishop is
still hanging and now if you move the
bishop you're gonna lose this pawn we we
now have it attacked three times so you
don't have time for that you're going to
have to give up your own bishop as well
and the white will be very very happy
here uh so instead we have bishop back
to h5 and only now bishop back to b3 and
now uh furuja is offering the the d3
pawn queen captures and d3 is possible
and this uh
actually happened in one very famous
game between magnus crossing and wesley
saw in the opera euro rapid this year uh
the game ended in a draw but wesley
captured on d3 and then you could uh you
know do
a lot here like bishop to c2 is very
interesting but magnus captured on e5
right away he offered the queen trade
here attacked black's queen and after
queen to f5 attacking the knight magnus
just brought the knight back and in the
end the game ended in a draw so it's
perfectly fine to capture this pawn uh
but sasikram plays king the h8 he unpins
uh from this um long diagonal now f5 can
be played also black is announcing that
black is very much interested in playing
f5
and now we have this very nice knight to
e4 putting pressure on the bishop here
so how do you defend it well you could
move it back bishop to d6 bishop to e7
but black plays knight to d7 now he's
offering the bishop to bring the knight
to c5 but uh alireza goes bishop to d5
and it's a very annoying setup you can
always capture here mess up the black
spawn structure the knight cannot move
because the bishop hangs so uh you know
a safe option would be to just move the
bishop bishop to e7 bishop to b6 uh or
uh yeah like bishop to b6 it was played
in many games but the white won all of
those games for example yanni pony she
had this against the arunyan and also
after bishop to b6 uh nipple was able to
win this game mvl had it against dario
schweitzer also after bishop to b6 white
won that game so here we have f5 and
this is a
really really uh
fun
fun and enjoyable move uh let me just
check something real quickly i don't
remember if i've seen this yeah and uh
pawn to f5 is a new move so already as
of uh move 13 we have a completely new
game
and what do you do here well it's a very
odd move because you weaken all of these
light squares and especially the e6
square
and of course uh there is a goes for it
just knight e to g5 if you capture the
bishop this is uh basically a force to
draw i'm just going to show you real
quickly it's basically a capture fest
captures captures and after captures on
c6 captures here captures an e5 captures
on d3 attacks the rook here and after
rook to e3 we can even play knight to e5
now saying okay uh you're attacking the
knight here but i'm threatening to
checkmate you so queen captures on the
e8 knight captures on f3 with check rook
captures rook captures and we get this
um sort of an end game where white can
even go bishop g5 attack of the rook uh
and everything just gets traded off
captures we're gonna play captures and
after rook captures g captures and we
have this uh rook and pawn end game
that's uh well if played uh
well should be a draw but of course
you're not interested in that when black
is giving you this opportunity of knight
to g5 followed by knight to e6 and it it
doesn't seem like black has all that
much to uh do about it is so it's a
straight out uh exchange sacrifice so
all it is it goes knight e to g5 and now
even h6 threatening to pick up the
knight and forcing the knight to go to
e6 now there are some other moves you
could play here but the position is
weird at best for black so we're not
gonna discuss that uh h6 attacking the
knight knight to e6 and now queen to f6
so developing the queen and also the
other rook will join the attack after uh
the exchange is captured so knight
captures and a f8 rook captures an f8
and now if you look at the position uh
okay black is up in development a lot by
a lot and uh well he has this beautiful
bishop pair here uh the queen rook and
bishop are all eyeing that uh f2 pawn
the knights could easily come into the
game for example if someone like e4 is
played then you allow knights to e5 and
could be very dangerous but there is one
move that really uh allows alireza to
take advantage of the positioning even
though he's uh
down in development and that is pawn to
d4 this is what alireza plays and you
can't really capture this pawn if you
capture the pawn rook to e6
and that's game over uh you just attack
the queen and after the queen moves you
don't have any other squares here uh
we're just going to play bishop capture
spawn captures and now even bishop
captures an h6 and black falls apart now
if you capture the bishop of course
we're going to capture with check after
the king moves we're going to pick up
the bishop on h5 and there's nothing for
black here so after d4 we have e4
attacking the knight here and the knight
can't move due to the pin here
d captures on c5 and now not capturing
the knight here uh but rather knight d
to e5 so attacking the knight here uh
and uh well we've reached the position
from the thumbnail almost uh so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the absolute best move for white
here
while i give you a couple of seconds
this is only for those who do not watch
the position on the thumbnail
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing you're
already up a piece so why not grab some
more pieces and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course knight captures on e5 we
sacrifice the queen and we go for that
d7 square to grab even more material so
there's really nothing better than
bishop captures on d1 uh this is what
the secret plate and now knight to d7
attacking the queen and the rook and h8
so queen to d8 and now not uh greedily
go uh going after the rogue because if
you capture this then queen captures on
the e5 and the bishop is defended uh we
can do much better so here alireza plays
bishop captures in c6 uh we have not b
captures on c6 if you play b captures on
c6 we capture on f8 and after queen
captures rook captures here and you have
two rooks and the bishop for a queen of
course this is uh winning for black so
after bishop captures on c6 we have rook
to e8 uh getting the rook out of harm's
way and then now only now rook captures
on d1 uh we have b cap on c6 and now
bishop to f4 uh having that e5 square
available for our knight to retreat is
very very important and you will not be
winning this night there's no way for
you to do it so here we have queen to h4
attacking the bishop and now you could
go bishop to g3 but just bishop captures
on c7 this is perfectly fine and now
black really can't just wait around
because if you allow a few moves then
this rook gets lifted the other rook
gets into the game and it's uh well
pretty much game over so we have to
decide whether we want to start
attacking with f4 or we want to start
attacking with e3 as the second doesn't
want to waste any time he decides to go
for e3 we have f captures rook captures
but now a rook lift comes either way so
rook to d4 attacking the queen and
you're not really gaining anything with
a with a single check that doesn't
really do all that much we are very
happy to trade our rook so queen back to
e7 first and now bishop back to f4 now
you don't want this bishop here so let's
move it with tempo the rook is attacked
and like we said if check then we
happily capture and after our king comes
to h2 we have a dark square bishop we
really don't care uh the the black queen
will not be able to pose any threat uh
for for the rest of the game pretty much
so we have rook to e2 black is
interested in keeping the rook on the
board and now comes b4 uh the b dupont
was uh under attack so uh you know
moving it um
out of necessity makes it all the more
sweet so white plays pawn to d pawn to
b4 uh and now black played queen to e8
it's uh
this could be the critical moment of the
game maybe for black because black here
could have continued a little bit better
maybe uh if g5 was played g5 in this
exact position is very dangerous because
for example if you bishop to h2 then
rookie one check and it's uh just
checkmate you don't even have to capture
the rook even if you move the king it's
still checkmate uh not like that but um
i like this uh and uh if you don't move
the bishop uh uh at h2 you're gonna have
to play something else for example if
you go knight to e5 this is this is
possible you could play bishop to e5
check or knight to e5 but knight to the
e5 is very interesting because you're
threatening knight to g6 check to win
the queen and here we would see an
exchange not an exchange sacrifice but
we're gonna pick up the two pieces for
the rook so captures captures and
captures now king f2 and now the other
rook is coming into the game so it's
still a very very difficult position for
black and black would suffer greatly
here but maybe with perfect play you
could uh maybe survive this although
still unlikely
but maybe it was the uh the best uh
chance for black however in the game
queen the e8 was played and now uh okay
now you could bring the queen to g6 and
check made to the white king but now
rook to f1 and now queen g6 can easily
be met with rook to f2 and we already
discussed how trading the rook really
does not favor black
so here we have queen to e6 and now rook
to f2 offering this trade uh and uh well
you don't gain anything by trading but
even if rook t won't check king h2
there's no way to continue this now but
now g5 doesn't really do anything just
bishop d2 and what do you do with the
rook there are no squares available for
it on the e file you're going to have to
move it and now rook d6 and that's
pretty much it the queen is attacked the
h6 pawn is gonna fall if queen captures
an eight you can even play rook to a to
now prepare rook to e7 then you can
capture so there's really nothing you
can you can do here so after rook cap
rook f2 we have rook capture sun f2
black finds nothing better now king
captures and the now queen captures on
a2 with check we have bishop to d2
blocking uh and now queen back to e6 and
now c4 now alyreza wants to play b5 and
create a pass pawn and win the game this
way uh so a6 uh preventing b5 for the
moment uh but now bishop to f4 now we
are always interested in bringing this
bishop to e5 to completely cut off the
black queen from
our half of the board so queen to e7 uh
and now we have b5 so no no no point in
waiting uh even though it's upon
sacrifice it doesn't really matter it
captures on b5 c captures on b5 and now
if this is captured just c6 and the pawn
is much too strong uh so instead the
queen to e6 is played now if captures
okay you can capture with the queen here
but uh of course fiduciary just advances
the pawn to b6 uh queen to b3 now
guarding that b7 square but just king g1
now we're going to bring our king to h2
where it's completely safe and only then
will we continue
uh playing this because black has no
plan here it's only white that can win
so g5 uh you have to try something but
now just bishop back to d2 and now we
have g4
and well the position is completely
winning for white but there is one uh
combination that is so beautiful that i
will ask you to find it so try to find
the move that alireza played while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that you
have to sacrifice everything in order to
win and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's rook to b4 uh
that's what alireza played and now
there's really nothing you can do the
pawn is going to become a queen and here
queen to d1 check was played but now
king h2 and you don't have anything here
it's interesting uh if you capture the
bishop alireza just pushes b7 you can
give up the rook as well and now we
bring the queen into the game and after
queens get traded off as this comes with
check we are going to pick up the queen
and now our end game is completely
winning because we're up a night for
example king g7 we're going to capture
on c6 and now this pawn is unstoppable
if king f6 we're going to play some like
captures captures knight to d4 and now
if king e5 just c6 if you go after the
knight to the pawn promotes if you go
after the pawn
the knight just defends it and you use
your king to pick up all of these pawns
and then promote this pawn so there are
many ways you can win this uh so instead
after king to h2 we have g3 with check
and now trying this king captures on g3
and now even f4 with check
and here alireza just went back with
king to h2 and it was in this position
on mu 43 that krishna and sasekaran
resigned to the game uh as there is
nothing more to be done here
it's very very interesting but even if
uh
even if
the king doesn't go back even if bishop
captures on f4 the position is still
winning so there's really nothing black
can do here if queen e1 check we can
just play king to g for if queen
captures on b4 even king f5 and now
there is nothing black can do to stop
this we're going to bring our king to c7
and promote this pawn uh if queen b1
check we just bring the king up the
board queen b3 check we bring the king
to d6 now we go here and then we promote
our pawn to a queen so absolutely
everything is winning here but he just
went back says black really has no other
moves and of course we already mentioned
that capturing the bishop uh doesn't it
doesn't work so there's really nothing
for you to try here
you could try something like f3 but
still just b7 you don't have anything to
worry about here you don't have time to
threaten checkmate because b8 comes with
check and then it's white who's on the
attack
uh so yeah after king h2 sikkim resigned
and a brilliant brilliant victory for
alireza firuja who uh it seems like he
won this one fairly easily
i mean there was a lot happening in in
in the game uh but uh if you know the
line and uh pretty sure alireza knows
this uh then then you know that uh black
messed up somewhere black mixes up some
lines and uh this is not how you
approach this and how you sacrifice this
exchange because after the exchange was
sacrificed uh this d4 move just
completely uh you know uh
nullifies
everything black had in mind there is
nothing black can do after this d4 move
it's simply so strong that if if black
knew about this d4 move when he decided
to go for this there's no way that he
would go for this so it's probably a
case of mixing up some uh lines of
preparation here uh but yeah uh once
again hope you guys enjoyed it and also
for those of you who are not following
the live ratings we're gonna check this
out as well uh look at this alireza is
now number four uh in the world he
overtakes yaniponishi the wheelchair
championship challenger uh on the live
ratings list and he is now only behind
uh magnus cross and dingler and fabiano
caruana and corona is still playing in
this tournament uh we'll see if he does
well then he will remain number three
but if he gets like two more draws and
alireza wins some games then we could be
seeing uh alireza as a world number
three after this tournament which would
be which would just be incredible not
only that he would also qualify for the
candidates and you know we could be we
could be witnessing history here uh so
yeah once again hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank james mayberry uh
abdel
frank holmes david leal and tom derelow
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it as usual
you can check to all my previous videos
here thank you for watching and i will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
this magnificent event uh checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day